[Musik]
hallo ich begrüße euch zu einem neuen
cheesecake rezept ich bin ja ein
absoluter cheesecake fanatiker und ich
kann sagen unser liebster cheesecake ist
der san sebastian tiefpunkt ich mache
die schlechte werbung für dieses rezept
aber auf platz zwei kommt der new york
cheesecake und deshalb kommt heute auch
eine art macy's krieg den sie aber mit
erdbeeren feiner und er ist auch mega
lecker und ich habe jetzt hier schon mal
vorarbeit geleistet ich habe butterkekse
fein gemixt und da kommt jetzt etwas
butter dazu die ich vorab in der
mikrowelle geschmolzen habe
[Musik]
s
der keks boden kommt dann in eine 20
zentimeter springform einfach schön
gleichmäßig verteilen und flach
andrücken und der kommt jetzt ganz kurz
zur seite
wir machen jetzt nämlich die cheesecake
masse das könnt ihr entweder mit einem
schneebesen oder ganz einfach die
küchenmaschine nehmen ganz wie ihr mögt
und die ganz genauen mengenangaben sie
stehen immer hier unten in der infobox
dann ist er neben dem titel einfach den
fall anklicken dann öffnet sie sich so
und jetzt habe ich hier doppel raum
frischkäse der gehört immer dazu zum
amerikanischen cheesecake ganz ganz
wichtig da habe hirschmann könnte auch
creme fraiche nimmt das komplett euch
überlassen tapezier schmandt da gehabt
ansonsten eier zucker vanille extrakt
und zitronenschalen abrief
[Musik]
und zum schluss kommt dann noch ein
bisschen mehl dazu einfach damit die
masse später besser bindet und dann nur
ganz kurz verrühren bis sich alle
zutaten miteinander verbunden haben
[Musik]
so die cheesecake masse habe ich dann
ganz einfach eingefüllt und noch ein
bisschen glatt gestrichen und jetzt
wandert sie auch schon in den backofen
bei 150 grad ober unterhitze ganz
wichtig den ofen immer vor und dann
sehen wir uns gleich wieder
[Musik]
neben mein käsekuchen es fertig gebacken
und jetzt muss nur noch aus grüner jade
hat keine risse ich habe in meinen trick
ich nehme immer einen holzstuhl oder
meinem fall sie die kuren kochlöffel
irgendwas jetzt so beständige scam das
zwischen die ofentür aber ich muss ganz
ehrlich was zu geben nachdem ist fertig
gebacken ist natürlich lassen dann
erstmal da auskühlt ist noch ganz
vielleicht lauwarm und gleich kommt
dafür mindestens vier schon in den
kühlschrank
aber ich muss sagen es kommt auch immer
darauf an was für die temperatur dann
hier im raum ist manchmal mache ich den
trick und habe trotzdem andere sehen
dürften nicht traurig sein wenn es dann
doch nicht klappt aber es auch gar nicht
schlimm denn lieber hamza und wir machen
sowieso noch im erdbeerpüree obendrauf
das haben würde das ähnlich erkenne ich
habe jetzt hier erdbeeren in einem topf
gibt da ein bisschen wasser dazu der hat
es noch nicht eingeschaltet
erst mal ein bisschen was er mit dazu
ich schreibe euch hier auch alle ganz
genauen mengenangaben in die infobox und
jetzt hab ich in meinem pürierstab und
püriert die einmal durch
[Musik]
als nächstes zucker und speisestärke
dazugeben schön türmchen frei verrühren
und dann erst den herd einschalten
sobald das ganze anfängt zu kochen zwei
minuten lange köcheln lassen und dann
habt ihr so eine relativ dicke soße und
das ist später unser topping das habe
ich jetzt ca 10 minuten lang ausdampfen
lassen damit jetzt die erdbeeren die ich
in kleine stücke geschnitten habe nicht
in die heiße soße kommt einfach rein
geben und dann mit dem cheesecake
zusammen servieren
[Musik]
unseren test habt ihr auf instagram
gesehen falls sie uns dort noch nicht
folgt dann ganz schnell nachholen
schreibe ich euch in die infobox
ich habe euch auch harmlos account rein
weil haben du machst meistens den test
ist und immer gnadenlos ehrlich
gnadenlos deshalb freut uns unbedingt
und ansonsten wünsche ich euch jetzt
ganz viel freude beim nachbacken
unbedingt ausprobieren ich liebe
cheesecake ich mache euch mal schießt
playlist von mir dann habt ihr alle
cheesecake auf einen blick und schreibt
mir gerne in die kommentare
welche variante noch sehen möchte und
dann sehen wir uns auch beim nächsten
mal hier auf meinem kanal schönes eure
kritik
[Musik]